well no country in the Western
Hemisphere has failed more completely in
more ways than Venezuela sadly has a lot
going for it had a huge middle class it
has of course the world's largest proven
oil reserves today it can't even feed
itself there's no toilet paper some days
in Caracas they're eating zoo animals
what happened well you know what
happened they implemented socialism and
they were obvious and predictable and
disastrous consequences but that's not
the whole story of what happened there
six years ago the government of
Venezuela passed a gun ban specifically
designed to disarm the public it of
course did not make people safer
Venezuela is one of the highest murder
rates in the world that wasn't the point
of it the point was to make the people
powerless and it definitely did that
as one terrified Venezuelan put it quote
people never would have believed they
needed to defend themselves against the
government but of course they did in the
past two years almost two hundred
protesters pro-democracy protesters have
been murdered by the security forces
have dictated Nicolas Maduro the
government still has guns of course
authoritarians aren't stupid they never
give up their guns that's rule one
well that principle applies just as well
at the United States as it does to
failing socialist States in New Jersey
ordinary citizens can go to prison for
possessing gun magazines that hold too
many rounds but lawmakers there just
change the law to ensure it doesn't
apply to police they know larger
magazines could be helpful helpful for
defense that's why their bodyguards
still have them regular citizens though
have to fend for themselves Bernie Kerik
is a former NYPD commissioner and he
joins us tonight when he thanks very
much for coming on so there are two
parts of this story the first part is
the state of New Jersey for a time made
it a crime for its own officers off-duty
included off-duty to have magazines that
I think hold more than ten rounds what
was the thinking behind that well
honestly
Tucker it was worse than that basically
they did it for the entire state of New
Jersey ten round capacity or less only
anything above that is a crime they did
it for the whole state when they did
that and and basically it was a cunning
way to attack the legal
owners because you have eight million
handguns in New York in New Jersey you
have probably another two million anti
assault weapons not not assault weapons
with semi-automatic weapons ranked
rifles they have you know capacities of
more than ten magazine ten rounds and
the government took that power away
which means you have to destroy the
magazines or you have to alter them and
most of them can't be altered so you
basically you make those guns useless
when they did this they also added
off-duty police officers which is
completely bizarre and it's it's another
assault on the Second Amendment but more
importantly you have all duty cops that
many of them carry they're on duty
weapon off duty of course if it's a
nine-millimeter it has 12 magnet 12
rounds in a magazine or 13 or 14 it now
becomes illegal so god forbid that cop
off-duty gets involved in a shooting and
he's held criminally liable he could
have be held civilly liable it's a major
major problem it's already back to
something you just said a second ago
because it gets to the heart of what
makes me nervous about this whole
conversation and why I'm serving says to
suspect the other side is arguing in bad
faith if you're worried about gun
violence and I think everybody is
including me for sure you go after the
small number of people who are
committing it who are criminals and
crazy people you wouldn't intentionally
target legal gun owners who are likely
to be law-abiding and in fact
statistically are law-abiding so why go
after them what's that about that's
about taking the guns that's about
taking guns that's the only thing I can
think of you know these are legal
law-abiding citizens that have been
vetted that have been background checked
that have all the stuff they need to
purchase the weapons well the governor
decided we're gonna take every magazine
in excess of ten rounds and basically
what that does that's a lot of magazines
but why would you so but I mean so your
goal if that's your if that's your plan
is to disarm legal gun owners to take
the resources from going after from
stop-and-frisk trying to find people
shouldn't have guns who possess them
criminals and go to legal gun owners
it's not really about reducing the crime
rate is it no absolutely not because you
listen the bad guys don't care about
your gun law they don't give it right
about that gun law and they're gonna
have magazines that have double the
capacity it doesn't make any difference
to them it's not gonna have any impact
on reducing crime so I don't know what
the purpose was but I do know right now
even as of now and this broke on
Thursday or Friday when the Bergen
County prosecutor put out a memo to the
cops saying be careful because of this
rule of this law even today as we speak
they've revised there's a revision to
the law but the governor hasn't signed
it so you still have cops in the state
of New Jersey right now off-duty if
they're carrying a magazine in excess of
ten rounds they are violating New Jersey
state law it's completely insane it
tells you a lot about where they're
coming from porn okay thank you very
much good thank you